la forêt amazonienne c'est près de 400
milliards d'arbres qui produisent une
vapeur d'eau qui se concentre en
précipitation qui arrose une grande
partie de l'Amérique du Sud
le Brésil possède plus de 60% de cette
forêt tropicale
[Musique]
l'Amazonie brésilienne brûle depuis le
début de l'année encore plus qu'en 2020
année record en septembre seulement 30
000 foyers d'incendie ont été repérés
par les satellites
l'an dernier pour la première fois
l'Amazonie émettait à certains moments
plus de CO2 qu'elle en absorbait
au sud les marais du pentanal ça sèche
se transforme en savane
les animaux dont le jaguar sont en
danger
les harpies féroces ces énormes rapaces
ont du mal à se nourrir
[Musique]
depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de JR
bolsonaro le premier janvier 2019 les
incendies augmentaient de 75% par
rapport à la décennie précédente une
catastrophe dise les écologistes quoi
le bilan du gouvernement bolsonaro
mauvais la déforestation a augmenté de
façon galopante bien plus que pendant
les 25 dernières années
[Musique]
le processus est bien connu et se
déroule dans la plus parfaite illégalité
d'abord on coupe le bois précieux
puis on brûle la forêt qui reste
et on la transforme en pâturage pour
l'élevage du bétail
suivez les routes et les mines d'or
clandestine des carrières à ciel ouvert
ou le dragage 24 heures par jour du fond
de la rivière modera par des barges
les orpailleurs isolent leur avec du
mercure qu'il brûle et dont les vapeurs
retombent en pure mercure dans l'eau qui
empoisonne les populations
octroie un vrai permis d'illégalité en
Amazonie le déboisement est illégal les
mines sont illégales en Amazonie il n'y
a ni loi ni ordre
patrimoine
comment
du monde
la destruction de l'Amazonie entraîne
une baisse des pluies pour le Serrado et
de la pollution jusqu'à Saint Paulo
l'Amazonie est notre plus grande
richesse il faut la protéger ce n'est
pas une question de droite ou de gauche
l'ex-président Louis Ignacio Lula da
Silva veut faire de la question du
climat sa grande priorité
mais même si son gouvernement a eu un
assez bon bilan s'attache ne sera pas
facile vu l'ampleur du désordre et de la
violence les écologistes pensent que la
solution passe par les communautés
indigènes les gardiens de la forêt dont
les territoires doivent être mieux
protégés
l'avenir de l'Amazonie et son impact sur
le réchauffement climatique sont loin de
préoccuper tous les Brésiliens si l'on
en juge par la puissance qu'ils ont
donné à jaillir bolsonaro au premier
tour mais l'enjeu est de taille et le 30
octobre prochain les yeux de la planète
retournés vers le Brésil Jean-Michel
Leprince Radio-Canada Rio de Janeiro